uh this you just have to see for more
than a year now
the right has been saying open
everything stop
masks open schools open restaurants to
full capacity
look at all these left-wing doomers
saying close everything forever
just open it up now of course over time
if we started to vaccinate people we've
started to open things but joe biden was
going too slowly for them or so they
said
he wasn't doing enough biden keeps
wearing his mask he's going too slowly
vaccinated people don't need masks
so last week the cdc comes out and says
hey we have more information about how
effective these vaccines are
and they are so effective that
vaccinated people don't really need
masks outdoors indoors
but still pay attention to state rules
and pay attention to the businesses
the rules of businesses that you're in
great fox news and right-wingers are
thrilled right
wrong check out all the new complaints
that these bad faith actors came up with
first
fox news runs a very suspicious story
pointing out that cdc chief moves from
impending doom
to no masks for the vaccinated in 45
days
on march 29th dr rochelle wolenski
warned the nation of
dire days ahead and yet suddenly
no more masks for vaccinated people in
many situations
pending state guidelines that's
suspicious even though she did what the
trumpists have been asking for
for a year even before it was safe to do
it totally bad faith totally pathetic
here's another one after this
announcement about masks from the cdc
joe biden also made a statement updating
people on the new cdc guidance for masks
fox news interviews
republican senator shelly moore capito
from west virginia
and the story is well why didn't joe
biden thank donald trump
why didn't joe biden thank operation
warp speed why didn't joe biden thank
alex azar can you imagine i know it's
laughable
but check this out were you struck by
the fact that the president did
he does not make a single mention of
operation warp speed
whether it's redfield or azar or jarrar
or president
trump none of that came yesterday how
come
well i mean i i'm always one that wants
to give credit where credit is
is warranted and certainly operation
warp speed president trump
put all of this into motion and and
president biden has followed through on
it
so the news isn't look at the progress
what great news joe biden and the cdc
liberating people
the story is biden said it but he didn't
thank trump
and he didn't thank robert redfield or
alex azar
or operation warp speed and yet if we're
giving
credit for putting things in motion
where are these very people
about the january 6th riots that donald
trump
put in motion they're very quiet there
it
really takes gumption to find something
bad about an announcement that they
wanted all along
that for the first time in over a year
if you're vaccinated if you follow the
cdc guidelines
you don't have to wear masks if joe
biden built a thousand miles of wall on
the southern border fox news would be
saying can we afford this
these immigrants are escaping drug
cartels after all
this is too expensive if joe biden said
guns for everyone no background checks
you got it republicans just have at it
newsmax would say what if a kid hurt
themselves
why doesn't joe biden care about kids
they deserve
none of our consideration as serious
participants in any discussion
because they aren't serious participants
in any discussion
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman